how long have you thought about being a
filmmaker you're 26 now right
so do you remember how old you were when
you decided i want to make films
it was um
it was right after high school that when
i entered um
lesser one as i
i knew that i wanted to do that but
when you in france when you
finish high school
there is no clear way of just
being a filmmaker when so when you are
uh and i think i think in the us uh it's
kind of
blurry also that's a gray area i mean
when you are
graduating i mean
i mean nobody knows really how
you enter a film school or what are the
film schools out there i think that's
which is kind of crazy because i think
filmmaking should be treated as a job as
a real job like other jobs and we should
show maybe the kids
okay so you can
go that way and learn that and go into
this school and learn
the craft there and i think that we it's
a common thing
here and maybe in the us and europe and
everywhere that
we lack a clear path to go and
be a movie director i mean when you have
a kid who say
i love movies i want to make movies
a lot of the time they don't know where
to go
which is sad i think
so why do you make films what's the
reason
i make films because i
i'm addicted to films
and i want to make stories that people
can be addicted to like i used to be and
like i am right now with other people's
movies
uh
i think
okay it's all about the story but it's
all
also about
creating a universe where people
can go back with their mind
a lot of time they can like i wish
people i'm making movies for people to
go
back at night
and when they're about to sleep think
about the movie and think about its
characters think about its universe and
just
i want a movie to still be with them and
to accompany them as they go in life
you talked about going to school near a
bunch of uh
you know movie theaters
when you walk in when you pay your 12 or
whatever it is correct what do you want
from a movie
what do you want for it to do for you
you mean right now or back in
either way yeah when you sit in that
chair you're like you know what i've
committed to two hours of my time right
i've paid the money i have my popcorn or
whatever it is what do you want that
movie to do for you
i want the movie to make me feel
something
truly i want to
feel
happy sad i want to i want to
feel something physical with you i mean
most of the films i truly love provoked
something visceral in me i want to feel
that
visceral thing in me i mean i want to be
crushed i want to be
i treat i mean want to feel like a human
being i think that's the goal at the end
of the day and that's why most of the
films i and the filmmakers i truly love
use this visceral aspect of film
which is for me one of the most
important
okay film is a cerebral cerebral thing
sometime but
for me and that's the kind of thing i
want to do i want to do something more
primitive more visceral something which
can
stick with people
right like blue valentine yeah
yeah exactly took you on just a
rollercoaster of emotions yeah right
right
i thought we were gonna say blue velvet
which is awesome sure yeah yeah i'm a
huge david lynch fan so